Bitte schön. Guten Morgen.
Schönen Morgen.
Ich heiße Mohammed Hamidi. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistentarzt tätig und wurde gerne mit Ihnen das Annemnesgespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie einverstanden? Gerne, gerne.
Zuerst stelle ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen und dann kommen wir zu Ihren natürlichen Beschwerden. Ist das in Ordnung?
Verstanden, okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Thomas Baum.
Baum?
Baum, wie der Baum.
U-M, ja?
Genau, Baum.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
Und wann Sie sind genau gebrochen?
5. April 1982.
5. April 1989.
80.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1.75.
Und ich wiege 80 Kilogramm.
80 Kilogramm.
Okay.
So Herr Baum, was führt Sie zu uns?
Ja, ich habe Sie aufgesucht, weil ich seit gestern starke Brustschmerzen habe in der rechten Seite.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Auf meiner rechten Seite.
Hier.
Und die machen mir Angst.
Und ich habe Angst, dass ich etwas Gefährliches haben könnte.
Seit gestern, ja?
Seit gestern haben wir, gestern Mittag.
Und sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ja, ganz plötzlich.
Und die gehen irgendwie nicht weg.
Die kommen und gehen, aber die gehen irgendwie nicht weg.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt hier in der Ambulanz, weil ich mir Sorgen mache.
Sie haben gesagt, nicht dauerhaft, ja?
Nein, die kommen und gehen.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Ja, so ein bisschen in den Rücken, nach hinten rum.
Und wir sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei alles sehr leicht und sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht.
Also, wenn die Schmerzen da sind, würde ich sagen 7, 6, 7 ungefähr.
Und bei Ruhe?
Also, in Ruhe habe ich die Schmerzen weniger.
Also, es ist dann 5 vielleicht oder 4.
Und sind die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen verstärkt sich,
die Schmerzen bei Bewegung, bei Belastung, bei Atmen?
Also, wenn ich eine Atme tut, das weh.
Bei Atmen tut weh?
Wenn ich eine Atme tut, das weh, ja.
Bei tiefen Einatmen, ja?
Genau, dann habe ich technische Schmerzen.
Und die Schmerzen sind stechen nur oder auch andere Beschreibung?
Nein, stechend würde ich sagen, pixend.
Pixend so ein bisschen.
Pixend?
Pixend, stechend.
Herr Baum, die haben gesagt, die Schmerzen nicht dauerhaft,
aber bei Einatmen sind sie sich verstärkt, ja?
Ja, genauso ist es.
Und haben Sie gemerkt, ob es Ausschläuser gibt,
für diese Schmerzen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Unfall?
Ein Unfall?
Unfall? Nein, keinen Unfall.
Haben Sie ordentliche Beschwerden irgendwann gehabt?
Nein, das erste Mal, deswegen bin ich hier.
Kann das ein Herzinfarkt sein?
Nein, diese Beschwerden geht nicht mit Herzinfarkt,
aber auf jeden Fall brauchen wir noch andere Fragen zu stellen
und andere Untersuchungen durchzuführen.
Und dann können wir darüber reden,
welche Diagnose, genau, die Diagnose haben Sie.
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Und Schütterfröst auch? Nein, ich fühle mich an sich ganz gut.
Ich habe nur diese Schmerzen, die mir Angst machen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Nachtschweiß oder Schweiß mehr als vor?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen eine Obel?
Und Erbrechen? Nein.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob Ihre Gewicht in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Ich habe mich nicht gewogen, aber ich habe nicht gemerkt,
dass ich abgenommen habe.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Sturrgang und Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Lust? Nein.
Und Herzrasen?
Ja, wenn ich Schmerzen habe, habe ich Herzrasen.
Also, da habe ich Angst.
Habt ihr Angst? Okay.
Ich glaube, ich weiß es nicht.
Haben Sie auch Schmerzen in dem Haas? Nein.
Okay, Herr Baum, ich stelle die Vorgeschichte über.
Haben Sie vor Erkrankungen oder leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel Bluthaubruck, Zuckerkrankheit, Schilddrose, Störungen?
Nein.
Ich habe keine solche Erkrankungen.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, in der Kindheit habe ich die Mandeln wegbekommen.
Und Kindheit, ja?
Ja, da war ich zehn oder elf oder so.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unfördwegligkeit gegen Lebensmittel?
Mich aber eine Katzenallergie.
Katze? Katzenhaareallergie.
Katzenhaareallergie.
Machen Sie denn ein EKG gleich?
Ja. Machen Sie ein EKG gleich?
Wegen dem Herzen?
Naja, ich denke, Sie brauchen keine EKG zur Zeit.
Wir machen ein EKG, aber das ist sehr selten bei einigen Menschen,
die Herz in der rechten Seite haben.
Ja, okay.
Das ist sehr selten.
Wir können EKG.
Also, das wäre mir schon wichtig, dass wir ein EKG machen.
Ich habe Angst, dass das in den Herzen gefragt ist.
Ja, okay.
Schreibe EKG.
Okay, Herr Baum, EKG gibt eine normale EKG.
So machen Sie keine Sorge über die Herz.
Herr Mahmett, Sie wissen nicht,
dass ein EKG, der
Kinderkrankheit und Corona geimpft? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich bin vollständig gegen das.
Wie viel Mal gegen Corona geimpft? Vier Mal.
Vier Mal. Gut. Haben Sie in der letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ich war nicht im Ausland. Nein, ich habe gearbeitet hier.
Herr Baum, rauchen Sie? Nein, das ist nicht gut rauchen. Deswegen rauche ich nicht.
Ja, sehr gut. Und trinken Sie Alkohol? Manchmal, wenn Freunde da sind.
Wie melden Sie manchmal am Tag? Manchmal am Wochenende, wenn ein Geburtstagsfeier ist.
Okay, Herr Baum, nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht versuellig. Das ist eine Routinefrage. Nehmen Sie Drucken?
Ich nehme keine Drucken ein. Nein. Ich habe noch nie Drucken angenommen.
Leiden Ihre Eltern eine chronische Erkrankung? Also meine Mutter hat eine schilddrüsen Erkrankung.
Und meine Vater hat Schilddrüsen Erkrankung.
Und welche Erkrankung wissen Sie? Nein, weiß ich nicht.
Und nehmen Sie Medikamente? Ich glaube schon.
Und Vater? Hab ich keinen Kontakt.
Was sind Sie von Beruf, Herr Baum? Ich bin Lehrer.
Und Sie haben sehr stresst, ja? Ja, also es geht. Ich war jetzt auch ein bisschen krankgeschrieben,
letzten Tage, aber alles gut. Ich gearbeitet jetzt aktuell. Ja, ich verstehe.
Und sind Sie verratet? Ich bin ledig.
Haben Sie Kinder? Nein. Haben Sie Geschwister? Ich bin einzig.
Okay, Herr Baum, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Müssten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder etwas an mich zu fragen?
Ja, ich habe Angst, dass das ein Herzinfarkt ist. Ich möchte gerne, dass Sie das ausfließen einmal.
Also ich möchte nicht, dass ich jetzt ein Herzinfarkt bekomme. Ich habe Angst.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen. Wir haben schon EEG gemacht.
Es gibt normale Herzfunktionen. Wir dauern mit den anderen Untersuchungen.
Das ist früher, genauer Diagnose zu sagen.
Aber am ersten Schritt, ich kann sagen, machen Sie keine Sorgen über die Herzfunktion.
Das ist sehr beschwerden, sprechen nicht vor Herzproblemen.
Muss ich dem Krankenhaus bleiben?
Wir müssen die Blutabnahme und andere Untersuchungen ergeben.
Dann können wir entscheiden, ob Sie stationär aufnehmen oder nicht.
Was machen Sie für Untersuchungen?
Ja, jetzt ist die Korberschwäntersuchung durch.
Abtasten über die Korbe und abhören.
Ich versuche Ihre Korbe.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Mandelentfüllung und das gerne mit chronischen Entzündungen in Ihrem Mund.
Ich habe keine Mandeln.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Mandelentfüllung und das bei einigen Leuten vor der chronischen Entzündung in dem Schleimhaus.
Ich habe Brustschmerzen.
Wir machen das gemeinsam unter Korberschwäntersuchung.
Ich lasse die Brust zweier rücken.
Das ist gut.
Wir untersuchen die Routine-Untersuchung.
Wir können weitere Untersuchungen brauchen.
Darüber können wir später reden.
Dann warte ich hier.
Sie warten sehr kurz Zeit.
Ich komme gleich.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ich habe keine Atemnot.
Wenn ich einatme, dann tut das weh.
Dann muss ich kurz mit meinem Atem anhalten.
Ich kann nicht tief einatmen.
Können Sie einige Treppe steigen?
Treppe steigen ist kein Problem.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie dort einen Aufschluss?
Manchmal, wenn ich das Fibes gegessen habe, dann ja, aber aktuell nicht.
Können Sie ein paar Treppe steigen?
Nein, das ist normal.
Haben Sie eine Medikamente?
Ich habe gestern einen Koffein genommen.
Wie viele Milligramm?
400.
Ich habe es einmal genommen.
Ich wusste nicht, ob ich das jetzt nehmen darf oder nicht.
Ich habe Angst.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss mich so bewegen.
Haben Sie auf dem Haut etwas Veränderungen bemerkt?
Ich habe extra geguckt, aber ich habe keine Veränderungen gesehen.
Sind Sie in der Lesterzeit im Krankenhaus gewesen?
Nein.
Können Sie eine Anfange machen, Mohammed?
Ja, okay.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen neuen Patient vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit vor mir?
Ja gerne, bitte schön.
Mein Name ist Thomas Baum.
Er ist 40 Jahre alt und genau geworden am 5. April 1982.
Er ist 1,70 m groß und wiegt 80 kg.
Der Patient hat heute bei uns wegen Toralgie gestern.
Wegen, wegen was?
Wegen Toralgie.
Toralgie.
Tor am Schmerz.
Der Patient berichtete, dass die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten sind.
Sie seien nur in dem Bestimmbericht lokalisiert.
Die Schmerzintensität entspricht 6, 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Bei Bewegung.
Und 4, 5 in Ruhe.
Bei Bewegung?
Stärker.
Aber auch in Ruhe?
Ja, auch in Ruhe.
4, 5.
Außerdem klagte der Patient, dass die Schmerzen bei tiefen Inspirationen verstärkt wurden.
Ja.
Die Frage nach Auslösa wurde verneint.
Er berichtete, dass die Schmerzen stechen.
Dass die Schmerzen stechen seien.
Er habe keine Unfälle gehabt.
Er hat gesagt, dass die Schmerzen als erste Mal gehabt haben.
Also die sind zum ersten Mal aufgetreten.
Erst mal aufgetreten.
Er hatte keine Husten.
Die vegetative Anemnese war unauffällig.
Die Frage nach begleiteten Beschwerden wurde verneint.
Vor Erkrankungen sind nicht bekannt.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob er Vorerkrankungen hat?
Ja, bei dem Patient wurde Tonzylaktomie durchgeführt.
Er nimmt die aktuelle Medikamente ein?
In Kindheit.
Er nimmt über Profen 400 mg nur einmal.
Hat er psychische Erkrankungen?
Er spürt immer vor Stress.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob er Medikamente einnimmt?
Er sagt nur über Profen.
Er hat andere Medikamente nicht erkannt.
Müssen Sie fragen, ob er psychische Medikamente einnimmt?
Er hat auch nicht.
Er drückt manchmal Alkohol am Wochenende und verirrt.
Die Familien an einem Nese ergibt eine Türoidellerkrankung.
Aber er weiß nicht, welcher genau ist.
Er hat mit dem Vater keinen Kontakt.
Er hat keinen Geschwister.
Er ist Lehrer vom Beruf.
Er ist leidisch und keine Kinder.
Er hat viele Stress bei Arbeit.
Er hat schweren Erhabe.
Er ist vollorientiert.
Er ist viermal gegen Covid-19 geimpft.
Macht er Sport?
Ich habe ihn nicht gefragt.
Er hat eine Reise an einem Nese.
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten?
Was machen Sie?
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten als Erstes?
Ich beruhige den Patienten.
Er ist sehr stressig und nervös.
Er hat eine korbische Untersuchung.
Er hat eine Blutabnahme.
Er hat 2 Ebenen.
Er hat eine Verwirbelsäure.
Er hat eine Vitalparametermessen.
Er hat einen EKG.
Wir haben einen EKG gemacht.
Haben Sie noch nicht mit dem Blutdruck gemessen?
Wir untersuchen für die Verwirbelsäule.
Sie müssen zuerst von dem schlimmsten ausgehen.
Sie müssen einen Herzinfarkt ausschließen.
Sie müssen das Herz ausschließen.
haben, Blutabmahmere gemacht haben, können Sie sagen, Sie haben erst mal keine Befürchtung,
dass ein Herz einfragt sein könnte. Das müssen Sie zuerst machen. Und anschließend können
Sie alle anderen Untersuchungen machen, weil das Herz ist das Wichtigste. Das müssen Sie zuerst
machen und alles andere kommt später. Vitalparameter, EKG, das ist das Wichtigste,
weil es könnte auch eine atypische Angenapäckteris sein. Das dürfen Sie nicht vergessen, auch wenn Sie
glauben, dass es kein Herz einfragt. Ich glaube, dass auch kein Herz einfragt ist, aber wir müssen
das beweisen oder wir müssen das objektivieren, mittels Vitalparameter und mittels EKG.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und anschließend können wir Röntgen-Torax machen und anschließend können wir Ultraschall
vom Herzen machen, Abdomen-Sono machen. Das ist das Wichtigste. Was könnte der Patient denn haben,
Ihrer Meinung nach? Was glauben Sie, was der Patient hat? Nach der Herzerkrankung ausschließen?
Ja, Sie haben ausgeschlossen, dass es ein Herzinfarkt ist. Also, EKG ist normal und Sie haben
einen Troponinschnelltest gemacht, vom Herzentroponin ist auch negativ. Was könnte der Patient noch haben?
Herz und Summen. Blut, okay, wir haben aber noch nicht das Ergebnis. Das dauert noch 45 Minuten,
bis wir das haben. Und ein Troponinschnelltest, Herzentzüme, Schnelltest ist negativ erstmal.
Haben Sie verstanden, was ich gesagt habe? Ja, Troponinschnelltest ist negativ.
Schnelltest ist negativ. Aber das ist nicht 100 Prozent. Richtig, ganz genau. Deswegen haben
Sie Blut abgenommen, aber das dauert noch bis es da ist. Es dauert 45 Minuten.
Wie lange ist der Oxygen-Viterparameter? Haben Sie gemacht? Ja, wir geben auf jeden Fall
Zerstoff, Oxygen. Ne, müssen Sie nicht. Wenn Ihr normal atmen kann,
müssen Sie das nicht machen. Was glauben Sie, was Sie haben? Welche Differenzialdiagnosen
kommen Ihnen durch den Kopf? Pleuritis, ganz nein. Pericarditis auch. Sehr gut.
Pneumotorax, sehr gut. Pneumotorax auch. Könnte sein, auch ja, aber macht normalerweise
keine Brustschmerzen, nur im ganz späten Fall. Und er hat keine Umfeld. Auch Pneumotorax, aber
vielleicht spontan Pneumotorax. Richtig, ganz genau. Wir hören ihn ab,
wir auskulpieren ihn. Wir machen Röntgen-Torax, ganz genau. Ja, und er hat keine
positive Besymptome. Wir können unter der Fragmetik-Abzess ausschließen. Richtig, Sie untersuchen
auch die Haut, ob er eventuell eine Zoster hat, herbest Zoster. Zosterneuralgie gibt es auch.
Ja, herbest Zoster. Richtig, herbest Zoster, genau. Sehr gut. Aber was ist hier, haben Sie alle sehr gut gemacht, was ist hier die Verdachtdiagnose?
Vor mir ist die Verdachtdiagnose Torackel-Wirbel-Säulis in Rom. Okay, kann sein, genau. Ja, und wir haben gesagt,
herzinfarkt. Kann sein, ein bisschen. Ja, und interkostalneuralgie. Das passt ein bisschen
besser, auch mit Ausstrahlung nach rechts, immer so zwischen den Rippen, das kann man auch nachfragen,
ob das punktuell ist, ob das an einem Punkt schmerzt oder ob das die ganze Seite ist, zum Beispiel. Bei
interkostalneuralgie, wie der Patient das auch beschrieben hat, das zieht meistens so ein bisschen
rum auch, an die Seite, im Rahmen dieser Zwischenwirbel, zwischen Rippenräumen. Ja, Schmerzen bei Inspiration
und Ausstrahlung. Und auch bei Druck, bei Druck meistens, ne? Bei Druck. Genau. Okay, was ist denn die Therapie
von einer interkostalen Neuralgie? Energetik, Spasmolitik. Ja, richtig. Und vielleicht
Beobachtung über die Bewegung. Ja. Ja, und vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ich bin nicht sicher, Inspiration,
Training. Training. Training, ja, zum Beispiel Physikeraten. Physikeraten. Genau, ganz genau, Physikeraten. Also
wichtig ist, dass wir bei dem Patienten, ich fasse nochmal zusammen, dass wir bei Torachschmerzen,
egal vorne, hinten, Bauch, oben und unten, immer herzenfakt ausschließen. Auch wenn Sie glauben,
dass er keinen herzenfakt hat, Sie müssten dem Patienten sagen, wir schließen einen
herzenfakt aus. So beruhigen Sie den Patienten, ja, und alles andere können Sie dann im Verlauf
machen, ne? Ja. Müssen Sie diesen Patienten stationär aufnehmen? Meine Meinung nach, ist
nicht aufs stationär Patient. Genau, kann man nach Hause lassen? Ja, nach Hause lassen. Kann man sagen,
kann ich morgen beim Haushaltsvorstellen? Ja, mit der gell-mesisch medizinische Kontrolle. Genau,
zum Beispiel, und vielleicht, wie gesagt, Physiotherapie, NSAR, über Profäen, Diklophenar,
vielleicht auch Novaminsulphon, ein bisschen Anergetika geben, wie Sie gesagt haben,
und dann geht das irgendwann weg. Manchmal geht es da ein paar Tagen weg, manchmal dauert es aber
einige Wochen, man weiß nie, wie lange das dauert. Und ich weiß nicht, vielleicht, weil
dieser Patient ist sehr ruhig und nervös, vielleicht ein Tag stationär, nicht für diese
Beschwerden, sondern für Allgemeine. Ne, müssen Sie nicht, müssen Sie nicht. Der Patient,
der Patient hat eine Depression. Auch haben Sie, haben Sie nicht gefragt, er nimmt auch
die Zitalopram ein, morgens einmal. Also er ist ein bisschen ängstlich auch, ja. Hätten Sie nachgefragt,
ob er eine psychische Erkrankung hat, dann hätte er gesagt, er hat eine Depression und er nimmt
doch Zitalopram ein. Ja, vielleicht zuerst, er hat nicht gesagt, weil vielleicht er fühlt
ein bisschen, nicht gut zu sagen Depression. Ganz genau, ganz genau, müssen Sie nachfragen,
immer nachfragen, organische Erkrankungen und nicht organische Erkrankungen,
psychische Erkrankungen. Ganz wichtig, nicht vergessen. Haben Sie Fragen? Hat jemand anderes
Fragen? Egal welche Fragen, können Sie jetzt stellen. Ich habe bitte eine Frage. Einen Meinung nach
von diesem Sphär, welcher am ersten Schritt als Diagnose, Verdachtdiagnose? Verdacht Diagnose ist
hier Torachschmerz. Ja, ich hätte wirklich an Interkostalinneuralgie gedacht, aber es kann
alles sein. Es kann auch Perikaditis sein, Ployritis sein, es kann Perikatamponade sein, es kann
alles sein, Herzinfarkt sein, alles sein. Deswegen müssen wir bei Torachschmerz immer ausschließen.
Man muss auch vielleicht ein Ultraschall vom Herzen machen, gucken ob alles in Ordnung ist.
Wenn alles ausgeschlossen ist, kann man sagen, es ist ein BWS-Syndrom, es ist eine Interkostalinneuralgie,
oder es ist eine Ployritis, vielleicht durch Röntgen-Torachs kann man das auch sehen. Dann
kann man den Patienten beruhigt nach Hause lassen wieder. Dann kann er gut schlafen und Sie können
gut schlafen. Ja, gut. Aber haben wir keine Zeit? Wir müssen zum Beispiel Vorgegenheit
wichtige Fragen stellen müssen, aber keine Zeit. Was machen wir? Wir müssen, wenn sowieso in
einer Zentralambulanz, wenn jemand mit Torachschmerzung kommt, bekommt er sofort ein EKG. Es wird sofort
Vitalparameter gemessen von den Krankenschwestern. Die Krankenschwester rufen Sie und sagen,
Herr Gündus, wir haben ein Patient mit Torachschmerzen, können Sie schnell kommen. Dann kommen Sie,
untersuchen Sie schnell und gucken Sie das EKG an, vielleicht tropfen und den Schnelltest. Dann
fragen Sie die Fragen, die Anamese, während Sie untersuchen den Patienten.
Ich bin ein bisschen erinnert, wenn ein Patient mit viel Schmerz kommt und ist nervös und hat keine
Geduldnis. Und das Schmerzmittel. Aber wir brauchen diese Schmerzen für richtige Diagnose, zum Beispiel bei
Bendezitis oder bei Kolezistitis. Was wir in diesem Fall machen? Ja, Sie müssen, wenn Sie den
chirurgischen Kollegen zum Beispiel, da müssen Sie ihn dazu rufen, wenn er Patient sehr stark Schmerzen hat,
dann müssen Sie ihm Schmerzmedikamente geben. Wenn er sagt, ich kann das nicht aushalten,
müssen Sie ihm Schmerzmedikamente geben. Sie dürfen ihn nicht warten lassen. Und Sie können
einen Ärzte dazu rufen, einen ärztlichen Kollegen und sagen, guck mal, er hat Schmerzen. Ich möchte,
dass du das auch siehst. Ja, und dann müssen Sie das dokumentieren. Anders geht das nicht,
weil Sie können einen Menschen nicht mit Schmerzen dalassen. Sie müssen Schmerzen
therapieren. Und wie können Sie das machen in der Prüfung bei Anamese? Sie können den Patienten
fragen, können Sie die Schmerzen aushalten oder soll ich Ihnen sofort etwas gegen Schmerzen geben?
Brauchen Sie jetzt Schmerzmedikamente oder können Sie noch ein paar Minuten aushalten?
Okay, wenn der Patient sagt, nein, ich kann nicht aushalten. Okay, dann gebe ich Ihnen jetzt
Schmerzmedikamente. Beziehungsweise ich untersuche Sie kurz, ich mache kurz die Untersuchung,
dann bekommen Sie sofort Schmerzmedikamente. Sie müssen sich ein Bild machen von den Schmerzen.